on passe maintenant à notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
michel delpech re bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes né le 26 janvier 1946 à courbevoie
dans les hauts-de-seine votre père était
artisan dans le chromage de métaux et
votre mère femme au foyer il est pas
encore aux havrais plus tard l'époque
d'étranges histoires les tourne-disques
la télévision et oui c'était des trente
glorieuses absolument alors
l'adolescence est fasciné par vos
premières idoles aznavour bécaud et vous
monter un petit groupe avec vos potes du
lycée de pontoise les pions flash sur
vous et vous emmène dans une maison de
disques les disques vogue ouais c'est la
maison de jacques dutronc c'est bien dit
dans les choses en fait s'enchaînent
plutôt bien vous rencontrer à ce moment
là votre compositeur attitré roland
vincent pour rencontrer votre première
femme chantal simon et vous faites votre
premier tube chez laurette magnifiques
chansons avant votre chance et là c'est
le succès vous êtes pris en main par
johnny stark et vous signez un contrat
de disques avec est débarqué ça à
l'époque c'est quand même lourd
personnages principaux et là vous
produisez une incroyable série de tubes
il ya inventaire 66 wight is wight pour
un flirt d'un seul coup vous êtes en
haut de la fiche mais vous en voulez
toujours plus à l'époque j'étais
extrêmement ambitieux 1 par exemple
quand vous rentrez dans un lieu public
si on vous reconnaît pas ça vous énerve
on est à peu près c'est vrai non bâti
j'avais j'avais commencé à chanter pour
en rendre partie pour ça ouais la
motivation de 2 à ses brise était trop
fort ouais c'est sa voix que je n'en
sais rien et chansonnier et à la musique
et koffi soir c'était surtout ce que ça
représentait qui m'excite et puis
surtout la peur que ça s'arrête vous
avez très peur à l'époque de redescendre
quoi voulez rester vraiment aux as oui
on a un peu boulimique le travail de
deux prestations ouais c'est comme ça
parce que c'est vrai
alors ouais c'est l'époque de tous les
excès l'argent les filles l'alcool la
drogue
parce que dire au final presque un
rocker
roulait en bentley et alors ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que vous êtes
tellement star est tellement adoré à
l'époque que vos admiratrices vous
envoient leurs poils pubiens par la
poste
alors malgré tous ses excès vous
continuez enchaîné les tubes alors que
marianne était jolie le chasseur enfin
les oies sauvages quand j'étais chanteur
le loir et cher sont extraordinaires
ça se passe extrêmement bien pour vous
êtes vraiment une star cros tard et là
votre couple commence à battre de l aile
vous étiez très famille modèle du
showbiz 1 ils sont toujours ensemble ils
ont deux enfants et tout mais en fait
modèle c'était à leur faux frais et un
jour votre femme chantal simon part
s'installer en polynésie avec son amant
ouais
et alors vous exploser en vol fait une
grave dépression nerveuse ou frôlé la
schizophrénie vous dites un locataire
s'était installé en moi sont tournés une
voie qui n'est pas toujours d'accord
avec vous oui c'était vraiment
fascinante d'extérieur qui me parle et
là un jour cette voie vous dis qu'il
faut en finir vous êtes sur une plage et
vous cherchez un endroit pour mourir
mais je me souviens de sa mère qu'est ce
qui fait que vous vous êtes arrêté
j'ai trouvé que je n'avais pas le droit
de mettre les gens de l'hôtel en bas
c'est une seule fois s'est placé à
passer chez vinaver c'est bien d'être
sauvé d'être sauvée d'un suicide par sa
bonne éducation ce extraordinaire
là vous demandez à faire des cures de
sommeil ans en hôpital psychiatrique
mais rien ne vous soigne et vous tombez
un jour sur un toubib il me dit écoutez
michel venir est jamais mieux de toute
votre vie donc il vous propose de vous
lobotomisés
alors là vous commencez à voir des
médecins des gourous des magnétiseurs
des voyants des marabouts que j'essayais
tout
se passe rien ne marche à un moment vous
tombez même sur l'hindouisme ou partez
en inde oui vous revenez le lendemain
non oui je rappelle
hélas après bien des péripéties un jour
venait d'acheter un billet d'avion pour
tahiti vous avez tous vendus réglez vos
affaires et un soir juste avant de
partir des amis vous invite à dîner et
là vous rencontré celle qui va vous
sauver la vie geneviève c'est incroyable
quand même nom générait vendu tous mais
tous mes meubles j'avais fait un espèce
de vente ouverte comme chien sur le
trottoir
devant la maison ouais et donc tous été
réveillés billets d'avion
si vous étiez parti à tahiti sur les
morts
jacobs a vraiment sauvé la vie
alors ça ne sera pas tahiti ce sera à
jérusalem avec geneviève un autre genre
voilà et là devant le saint sépulcre
vous retrouver la foi finalement vous
trouvez le christ j'ai eu une sensation
très forte de rencontres
en fait des retraites à l'époque chez
les bénédictins saint wandrille nous
vient du bien j'adore
à partir de là vous sortez des disques
plutôt confidentielle par rapport à tout
ce que vous avez fait avant jusqu'en
2006 où là vous sortez un album de duos
exceptionnels qui vous remet tout de
suite en tête des ventes mais le 20
février 2013
alors que vous devez participer à la
tournée âge tendre et tête de bois pour
la troisième fois vous annulez votre
participation
vous allez c'est vrai à cette époque-là
de plus en plus de mal à finir vos
comptes r vous êtes habite souffle vous
êtes épuisé
j'allais voir un toubib ne suis pas ce
que j'ai et le diagnostic est terrible
cancer de la gorge et cancer de la
langue c'est à dire en ce qui vous
concerne cancer de la voix française
a besoin c'est quoi une cigarette et
paraît
fumier depuis toujours ouais il ne paie
l'âge de 17 ans
et la grâce à dieu geneviève est là et
elle vous dit on va se battre ensemble
pour éradiquer cette saloperie donc elle
est de nouveau là
d'affirmer ouais ça lui plaît
alors le problème c'est que la tumeur
est trop profonde pour être opéré donc
on va vous faire de la radiothérapie
mais sans toucher les cordes vocales
évidemment donc ça a été très long et
très compliqué jamais messieurs et de
professionnels un mois a été extrêmement
précis vous n'arrivez pas à penser à la
main en fait vous avez cette foi en
jésus-christ qui vous qui vous êtes
vraiment à tenir et à voir les choses
avec courage oui c'était sûr c'était de
l'inconscience mais j'étais sûr de le
guérir j'ai douté des suites qui
pourraient
avoir et d'ailleurs qui sont ils sont
encore là problèmes d'élocution et ses
seins je n'arrive pas
à résoudre totalement et d'ailleurs vous
vous suivez là encore des cours
d'orthophonie oui ça progresse ça
progresse très lentement à ça progresse
vous entraînez
vous ressentez
c'est tout le mal qu'on vous souhaite en
tous les cas est vraiment comme dit
j'aime bien vous êtes vraiment le phénix
quoi deux fois de suite vous en être
sorti quand même
je
[Musique]
j'adore cette chanson me
alors aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui vous revenez avec un disque
intitulé de libé bol c'est l'ancien
testament chanter aux enfants il ya une
chanson vous avez enregistré avant
d'être malade mais qui est très très
belle qui s'appelle la fin du chemin et
c'est des paroles absolument
prémonitoire ne sonnait pas la fin du
chemin merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu